did you ever daydream of being a
superhero as a child as the protector of
justice and defender of all that is good
most kids did i'm sure making your own
secret bases with your best buds and
sharing in adolescent fantasies crafted
around the stories you read in comics
and manga
far from being unusual these are the
common occurrences that make us look
upon our childhoods with a familiar
nostalgia
but of course when making those heroic
tales there's no way you can have a
great hero without a cunning villain to
act as their foil
who is light without l young wenly
without reinhard gone without the
perverted and depraved clown man
and so you would construct these cool
complicated villainous schemes that the
great hero would have to battle against
huge robots anti-proton bombs killer
viruses that sucked the blood out of
your body akin to the horrors of bram
stroker's dracula
and then
you grew up
you witnessed those fragments of your
imagination disappear with the other
childish hopes you once had and you
submit yourself to the all-encompassing
system that crushes hopes and subjects
you to the monotony over the world
life
but what if those nefarious ideas you
thought up for the villain
weren't dismissed as the naive
aspirations of young children what if
you woke up one day only to realize that
a man was beginning to carry out those
villainous schemes you once daydreamed
of to their most horrifyingly real
extent
huge robots
bombs
killer viruses
those childhood fantasies are now coming
to life and terrorizing the world
and you and your friends are the only
ones who might have the key to stopping
it all as the ones who created this plan
so many years ago
this is the story of 20th century boys
by naoki orozawa renowned mangaka and
creator of other beloved manga series
monster
the story follows endo kenji a normal
convenient store manager just trying to
get by
he's long forgotten many of those lofty
aspirations he once had as most kids do
he abandoned his teen love for the
guitar and rock and roll and having to
take care of his missing sister's baby
daughter ties him down to a life he's
not particularly satisfied with
however things quickly begin to take a
turn in this ordinary life when one of
his childhood friends donkey
yes that that was his nickname donkey
commits suicide
and a new cult begins to extend its
reach into every crack and crevice of
society led by a charismatic man they
call
friend
and kenji soon realizes that this cult
is enacting a scheme
far more sinister than it seems on the
surface
world domination
and it's all according to the master
plan that kenji and his friends once
drew up as children
as kenji becomes tangled up in vast
conspiracies and dangerous mysteries he
is left with no other choice but to
abandon the peace he once had in life
in order to wage war against this
overwhelming power that his friend and
his followers and prevent what they will
enact onto the world
kenji must gather his old friends who
have all embarked on their own paths of
life and unexpectedly
become the heroes of justice they once
aspired to be
[Music]
just as naoki orozawa did with monster
before this not only does he write
compelling and tragic main characters
but even more so brilliant and eternally
memorable villains
follows in the footsteps of johann
liebert by being one of the most utterly
mysterious
compelling sadistic and devilish
antagonists to step foot onto a manga
page
in this way both stories follow a
similar narrative in that the hero tenma
and monster and kenji and his friends
and 20th century boys must unravel the
twisted story of their respective
nemeses who were ironically birthed out
of the actions of the heroes themselves
and they must stop them
it sets the foundation for a beautiful
dynamic between the two main characters
in a sense as the protagonist carries
the burden of guilt for every action the
antagonist takes knowing that they were
the ones who allowed this to happen
friend's desire to rule the world is
both insatiable and ingenious with the
funny contrast being that his intricate
master plan is simply taken out of the
old drawings of a group of pre-pubescent
boys in the 70s
in this sense kenji and his friends lay
out the plan for exactly how anyone with
enough determination could rule the
world as friend follows just that but
how are you supposed to rule the world
without knowing all of its languages
this video about 20th century boys is
brought to you by rosetta stone an
excellent language learning program that
can immerse you in no time in whatever
language you choose
from
[Music]
[Music]
if you want to watch anime without
subtitles or simply just learn japanese
or any other language for that matter
or susumedial
the lifetime subscription for rosetta
stone is normally 299 dollars but if you
click on the link in my description you
get it almost 50
off this means that you pay only 180 for
interactive japanese study materials for
life you can take it at whatever pace
you want and only have to pay once for a
lifetime of learning and if you end up
buying it and realize that you don't
want it it's all okay because there's
still a 30 day refund for your full
money back so click on my exclusive link
below if you're interested otherwise
friend will have you purged
i'm joking
or am i
one of the most beautiful aspects of
20th century boys and naoki odasawa
stories in general is exactly that
the unpredictability of characters and
the blurred lines that they have between
good and evil
though it often feels in stories that
anyone against the protagonist is evil
for example many shonen manga make this
distinction simple and obvious for the
sake of building up a brave and strong
hero who stood up against the
incarnation of evil itself
one of the main lines of questioning
that 20th century boys investigates
is who is good kenji and his friends are
fighting to protect the world yes
but they're defending it from their own
machinations
on the other hand friends plan though it
does include taking innumerable lives
and hurting millions
is one that also unites the lost souls
of the world under his cult's wing under
the guise that he is in fact their
friend
and who's to say that he actually isn't
further adding to this 20th century boys
follows the cast of characters through
many different areas of their lives with
time skips aplenty going from 1969 as
children all the way until 2018
this allows us to personally witness the
changes in each character over time and
how their upbringing has molded them
into who they are in the future how the
battle against friend changes them their
hopes and their idea of what is truly
evil
as exemplified in the manga's title much
of the story revolves around kenji and
his friends when they were young boys as
the root of
well
everything
like how the rise of rock music in the
late 60s made kenji into a hopeful
musician and firm believer and the
culture of freedom and authenticity that
the music brought with it
likewise after learning bits and pieces
of friend's story you begin to see his
motives what it stems from and why he
would use kenji's childhood plan of all
things to enact world domination
all of kenji's friends have traveled
their own paths as adults
not all of them are fully on board to
risk their lives to supposedly save the
world they have families or they've left
the past behind them
this story is one of the few times where
the entirety of its huge cast truly have
their own personality and my opinion
their own arcs and stories that truly
make the title 20th century boys
befitting rather than focusing on a
single one of the boys or a single
character
in fact i'd say that a lot of the manga
doesn't even directly follow kenji
though he and friend are at the
epicenter of it all urasawa's attention
to everyone else fleshes out this story
in a non-linear and immensely
imaginative way
and to return to the idea of blurred
lines between good and evil when you
look at all these other members of the
cast the story asks
are you good if you decide not to
abandon everything to take up arms
against a supervillain in what seems
like little more than a childhood
fantasy and instead stay back to support
your family
or are you evil for choosing not to save
the world when you had the chance
is kenji evil for bringing his friends
into this risking their lives
when the burden of it all really weighs
on his shoulders
these are the questions you consider as
you read the story and it's the
questions the characters themselves
consider as well
many of the characters have a sense of
guilt as they debate these questions but
they never really get answered
because of course
it's simply not that easy
because of this tender balance between
good and evil kenji and friend are not
like light and darkness
not opposites but
more akin to two sides of the same coin
more so than anything else
20th century boys reflects the
importance of life in many different
facets of that meaning
for one simply the importance of
persistence in life
what's great about witnessing a story
that occurs over such a long period in
these characters lives is that you can
see them fall and witness whether they
stay down or get back up and keep trying
against an all-encompassing almost
omniscient force like friend with allies
in every corner how can you keep telling
yourself that you can win
how can you devote your life to a battle
you may never see the end of
but a great manga never shoves these
ideas down your throat
20th century boys does it through subtle
details
they ask these questions through the
discussion of a game of bowling
or over a measly bowl of ramen only a
few words shared
but you begin to understand the
importance of self-reflection once you
get older and as these characters get
older as well
considering what has brought you to
where you are and whether this is what
makes you happy
and is there a point to doing it if it
doesn't
how lasting relationships make life
worth living and the importance of
forgetting and forgiving others and
atoning over time
there is so much to take away from this
story and even its smallest moments
it makes you reconsider the way you've
lived your life
and the impact that your formative years
have on who you become
more than telling you the explicit way
to rule the world
20th century boys offers insight into
how perhaps the key to making the world
you want to live in and molding it to
your own ideas
lies in your imagination
it's a reed that can't be passed on
if you've got this far thank you for
being patient while i kind of took a
break from the channel i've got more in
store over the summer and
keep an eye out it'll be great
also do check out rosetta stone if
you're interested make sure to click on
the link below in my bio thanks guys
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyses